PRESIDENT TRUMP IS GOING TO MEET
WITH CONGRESSIONAL LEADERS
TOMORROW TO TRY TO HAMMER OUT A
DACA DEAL.
DEMOCRATS AND ESTABLISHMENT
800,000 ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS UNDER
THE DREAMERS.
THAT GIVES THE PRESIDENT A LOT
OF LEVERAGE TO GET WHAT HE
WANTS.
WHAT WE NEED.
IF TRUMP IS GOING TO GIVE THE
DREAMERS ANY KIND OF LEGAL
STATUS, I HAVE A SENSIBLE
THIS IS ALL GOES WITH WHAT HE
CAMPAIGNED ON.
NUMBER 1 BUILD THE WALL.
GET THE FUNDING.
NOT A PUNY DOWN PAYMENT.
I HEARD 1.6-BILLION DOLLARS.
BUILDING THE WALL IS A TOP
PRIORITY FOR THE VOTERS.
ENDING CHAIN MIGRATION.
OUR SOCIETY.
NOW YOU NEED IS A SECOND COUSIN
SEASON AND ENDTHE JOKE OF THE
DIVERSITY LOTTERY SYSTEM.
WHEN NATIONAL SECURITY IS
THREATENED, WHAT IS THE POINT OF
ADMITTING IMMIGRANTS AT RANDOM.
THE LOTTERY SYSTEM SHOULD HAVE